so with the age of apocalypse continuing
in the next few days and Jon Bernthal
being confirmed to play the role of the
Punisher in season 2 of daredevil I
figured why not make a video about
Punisher kills the Marvel Universe now
keep in mind as with stories like this
and Deadpool kills the Marvel Universe
this takes place in an alternate reality
so the story picks up with both Frank
Castle and Matt Murdock as kids and
really seems to set the stage for the
mind of Frank Castle and that he
discovers Matt Murdock is being bullied
by various other kids in response to
this the Frank Castle beats up the kids
and then forces them off of Matt Murdock
and so what happens is that Matt Murdock
and Frank Castle seem to become friends
or at the very least Matt Murdock
becomes someone that Frank castle looks
out for now following this Marvel just
jumps forward here and they don't really
give us any insight into the later years
of either character that is to say what
happened as they grew up what we find is
that we're in the normal earth-616
reality that is to say the main Marvel
Universe the Frank hassles family had
basically died due to being caught in
the crossfire of a gangland shooting but
in this universe we join what appears to
be some kind of a massive battle in
Central Park involving the x-men and the
Avengers who are fighting the scrolls
now the result is that Frank Castle
actually overhears the conflict since
he's part of the NYPD SWAT team then he
recalls that his wife and children had
been spending the day in Central Park
and so once he arrives he realizes that
multiple innocents had been killed in
the conflict which included his wife and
kids now while Cyclops of the x-men
initially tries to explain that the
attack happened at the last minute and
if there wasn't really time to evacuate
anybody Frank Castle doesn't want to
hear it and instead he simply takes out
his gun and he shoots Cyclops in the
face along with Jubilee and Hawkeye now
the result here is a Frank Castle is
immediately attacked by Wolverine but
Wolverine is actually subdued by
Colossus and Frank Castle is placed
under arrest now at this point we jump
to Matt Murdock who's representing Frank
Castle during his trial but because of
Frank castles history with the Marine
Corps and because he had murdered some
of the biggest heroes of the time Frank
Castle is basically sentenced to life in
prison however
while Frank hassel is presumably being
transported to Rikers Island where hosts
serve out his sentence he actually finds
when he arrives at his destination that
is actually the home of a man named
kesselring now what happens here is that
kesselring along with various other
individuals represent the victims of
people who had been killed in conflicts
involving superheroes and supervillains
and so what Kesselring says is that this
society appears to be turning a blind
eye that is to say everybody else in the
world governments and things like that
but they seem to be turning a blind eye
to the death of innocence so long as
these superheroes win and so what
happens is a kesselring and his group
agree to finance the operations of the
Punisher if he's willing to go about the
mission of killing anyone and everyone
who refers to themselves as
super-powered whether they be heroes or
villains and so with the death of his
family weighing on his mind
Frank hassel agrees and so at this point
we jump to spider-man and venom who are
actually fighting in the sewers of New
York now Marvel doesn't really give us a
long drawn-out scene here instead
while both spider-man and venom are
fighting The Punisher sneaks in and
basically bombards the two of them with
electric Barb's that incapacitate the
two and actually cause venom to revert
back to his normal form of Eddie Brock
now one spider-man realizes that the
Punishers killed venom spider-man Begins
pleading with Frank hassel asking why it
is it he has to die and in what I
considered to be one of the coolest
moments of the story he doesn't really
answer spider-man directly he simply
just shoots him and then we switched to
the Punisher simply saying that someone
had to be the first person to die now
from here we jump to the Incredible Hulk
and I think this is something that a lot
of people were curious about how was the
Incredible Hulk going to die at the
hands of the Punisher or what happens
here is the Incredible Hulk appears to
be either rampaging or fighting a
villain we don't know and in fact Marvel
if he is fighting a villain they don't
show us but what happens here is that
Frank Castle views or watches the Hulk
and shoots him with a tranquila
tranquila uses this kind of I guess
homing signal of some kind or some kind
of a homing device and follows the
Incredible Hulk
and once the incredible hold turns back
into Bruce Banner Frank Castle shoots
him now
the big question under normal
circumstances we would assume that the
Incredible Hulk or I'm sorry the Bruce
Banner would probably transform into the
Incredible Hulk and spit the bullet out
Marvel doesn't do this instead with the
Incredible Hulk and like will see with
Wolverine Marvel simply just says
they're dead and that's it they don't
really give us any kind of an
explanation in terms of what would
normally happen under this circumstance
regardless though what we do here is we
follow Frank hassel as he meets up with
a hacker sidekick named microchip and
microchips actually assisting Frank
Castle with the information I guess
getting him the information he needs in
order to take down the various
superheroes what we find here is that
Frank castles next intended target is
the kingpin and with the help of
microchip Frank castles actually able to
subdue the entire security system and
the security forces of the kingpin and
eventually confront the king the kingpin
himself now where kingpin initially
states that he believed Frank Castle was
only targeting heroes and that the
kingpin had actually applauded his
actions and even created this huge store
of weapons of Frank Castle key to use
what happens is that the kingpin
realizes the Frank castles targeting
both heroes and villains and so what
ends up taking place here is a scuffle
between the two of them at Frank Castle
actually shoots the kingpin in the eye
and so what happens is that the kingpin
seems to jump onto Frank Castle seems to
physically grab him but Frank castle
uses his gun and he shoots kingpin in
the bottom of the head which basically
comes out the top and it kills the
kingpin and so the kingpin actually
lands on Frank castle with Frank Castle
stuck underneath him and so what happens
is that the authorities arrive and they
subdue Frank castle and they take him to
take him to jail and of course he's a
sentence to life in prison again for a
second time now the issue here is that
Matt Murdock is basically trying to
operate or trying to get Frank Castle to
understand the ramifications of his
actions he's trying to tell him that if
he keeps going down this path that
things are going to end badly either
they're going to end badly for Frank
Castle or they're going to end badly for
everybody the Frank Castle knows which
in truth isn't really a way to appeal to
Frank Castle since as far as he's
concerned everybody he cares about is
dead but at this point what we do is we
find that when Frank castle is being
transferred to prison a second time that
again his transfer
intercepted by kesselring and they bring
him before the community I guess the
Society of kesselring and Frank Castle
goes about the process of continuing his
mission again now at this point we jump
back again with Frank Castle and
microchip as they enter the domain of
Latveria and dr. doom what we're told
here is that using some kind of a
scrambler device that was among the
stored weapons of kingpin that microchip
was actually able to disguise their
helicopter as a Fantastic Four's
fantastical I think is how it's
pronounced but what happens here as
Doctor Doom believes that the Fantastic
Four are actually coming to visit him
and so what ends up happening is he
actually allows the allows the group to
enter or allows Frank Castle and
microchip to enter his domain not
knowing it's the two of them and so once
Doom realizes that it's Frank Castle the
two of them engage in a conflict and
doom immediately gains the upper hand
but what ends up happening here is Frank
Castle actually takes a magnetic mind
and attaches it to the head of doom
which detonates now what Frank Castle
says is that this serves two purposes
the first purpose is to cause a feedback
loop that will destroy the doombots and
the second is my extension of the new
BOTS being destroyed it will help Frank
castle figure out which Doctor Doom is
the real one now once Frank Castle
realizes that the Doctor Doom he's been
fighting this whole time is actually the
real Doctor Doom and not a robot he
takes a hammer down from off the wall
and basically beats dr. doom to death
with it now from here we follow
microchip and frame Castle again to
below the castle of Doctor Doom and they
actually end up locating a nuclear
warhead and the reason for this is
because as Frank Castle explains he's
basically going to start going against
characters especially with having
defeated Doctor Doom going against
mutants and super-powered beings where
guns just aren't going to be enough and
so what we do is we switch to the x-men
x-factor and the x-force teams on the
moon as they're preparing to do battle
with the forces of magneto apocalypse
and mr. sinister now initially each
group had believed that the other had
summoned them there but when they
realize that they've been gathered under
false pretenses the nuclear bomb goes
off
and so basically Frank castles use a
nuclear warhead to kill all of the x-men
and presumably a huge majority of the
mutants now again with characters like
apocalypse we would most likely assume
they could serve
of a nuclear explosion but again Marvel
doesn't address this Marvel simply just
says they're all dead that they're
they're non-existent in this universe
anymore now from here we jump to
Wolverine and what Wolverine does here
is he actually gives us a fair bit of
information what wolf rein tells us is
that the from the time the x-men had
died up until the current moment that
three years had passed and that during
this time Frank Castle has killed five
hundred heroes and villains from around
the world including the Avengers the
Fantastic Four with only Captain America
Wolverine and daredevil left now during
his inebriated state Wolverines actually
joined by Frank Castle and after a brief
scuffle Frank Castle throws Wolverines
body into an electrical generator which
seems to overload Wolverine and actually
disintegrates his entire body leaving
only his adamantium skeleton behind now
again we seen instances where Wolverines
body has been disintegrated or else
burned all the way down to his
adamantium form to his adamantium
skeleton and he's revived here but that
doesn't happen in this story instead
Wolverine is just dead Marvel just kind
of leaves it at that now at this point
we jump to Captain America and while
he's in the middle of fighting Frank
Castle what seems to be happening here
is that Frank I'm sorry Captain America
states that he's going to end Frank
castles campaign he's going to stop
Frank castle once and for all but the
kicker here is a Captain America had
fought in World War two and Frank castle
had fought in Vietnam and what I mean by
this is that as Frank Castle explains
here
Captain America fighting in World War
two with the way that he fought and they
kind of skirmishes he or he was involved
in those did not require guerrilla
warfare tactics it is to say hiding in
bushes setting mines doing ambushes
things like that but Frank castles time
in Vietnam did and so what happened was
a Frank Castle actually lured Captain
America to this location then when he
did he had stationed various weapons
hand's handguns and so on around this
little I guess miniature patch of land
and so what happened here was that while
Captain America was making his speech
about how he's going to end Frank Castle
and so on and so forth Frank Castle
grabs a sidearm and then shoots Captain
America in the head now for here we jump
to the last fight which actually takes
place between Daredevil and
hasil now while the two are fighting
daredevil is constantly attempting to
persuade Frank castle to stop but Frank
Castle simply just doesn't now we're
dead devil is initially able to outright
or I guess the out fight and subdue
Frank Castle daredevil also states that
regardless of Frank castles anger
towards those that killed his family
they were so people and so Frank Castle
counters this by saying that heroes and
villains have adopted this attitude that
because they have powers that they can
determine how the world is supposed to
be and that those who get in their way
or simply just casualties and so the
problem here is that when daredevil
reaches to extend a hand to help Frank
Castle up presumably a kind of olive
branch of friendship the Frank Castle
actually stabs him in the stomach and so
what is up happening here is Frank
Castle takes off the mask of daredevil
and when he does he realizes that
daredevil is his longtime friend Matt
Murdock and so what happens is that at
this point Matt Murdock says that
there's always someone under the mask
that people under the mask have friends
they have families and so on but Frank
Castle didn't see that because he was so
swept up in his quest for vengeance he
didn't stop to think
and so what daredevil says is that Frank
Castle has killed all the superheroes
he's killed everybody there's no heroes
left but Frank Castle stops and says no
he says there's still one hero left for
him to kill at which point he turns the
gun on himself
and pulls the trigger and that brings it
into the story
it's a single-issue story it is in my
opinion one of the best Punisher stories
written it's it's pretty fantastic but
it's nowhere near as good as Punisher
max but it's pretty fantastic but yeah
so I hope you guys enjoyed this video if
you did let me know and I will catch you
guys let him peace